it's great to have you here today more
for the premiere of infinitely polar
bear and in this movie we actually got
two superheroes yourself and Zozo Dona
playing very real-life characters tell
me what attracted you to this movie well
it's not so ordinary a family it's you
know that's a bipolar father raising his
two mixed-race daughters in the 70s on
his own it's very funny and touching and
it's based on a true story it was
written by my forbes who was actually
one of the girls and it's played by my
daughter's played by her daughter and
it's just an incredibly beautifully
touching and funny little movie about an
extra an extraordinary family how does
it compare making a movie like infinity
pearl about very independent movie two
massive things coming up we've got the
age of Ultron of course we've had
Avengers with you as well yeah
well when the cameras rolling you're
still doing the same thing but when the
camera is not rolling there's a lot more
bigger sets more people more equipment
better lunches generally just a lot more
stuff and what about the standalone Hulk
movie I'd love to do a standalone movie
for the Hulk here that Marvel I love
that
you